so today we're going to continue with
genetics and we're going to talk about
the rules or laws of inheritance
I expect that many if not all of you
have been exposed to these rules before
and so what I really want to do today is
make the connection between these laws
and the behavior of chromosomes such
that when you're thinking about genetics
and inheritance pattern you're thinking
about chromosomes undergoing meiosis
okay and I want to start just to make
the point that there are a number of
human traits and human diseases that
show clear sort of inheritance patterns
and what's shown up here is what's known
as a pedigree okay so this is a pedigree
I'll just block this off I'm showing you
a pedigree which shows relationships and
a family tree and so what you can see
what these symbols denote are if you
have a open box that is an unaffected
male and so openbox is an unaffected
male and what I mean by unaffected is
and usually it means they don't have the
disease that we're talking about okay
circles represent females and so an open
circle would be an unaffected female
[Music]
and finally if you have one of these
symbols either male or female and it's
shaded in that by convention represents
an affected individual so that's an
individual that has the disease or trait
so this is an affected individual okay
so this is an example of a disease that
you've already heard about from
Professor Imperioli this is a family
tree that's indicative of a type of
inheritance that's seen in families with
a disease called phenylketonuria
okay and you'll remember from Professor
and Perry Ali's lecture this is a
disease where there's a mutation or
allele in which there's a defective
enzyme that can't process the amino acid
female v + O alanine and so patients
with this disorder have to be very
careful about their diet such that they
don't in take too much phenylalanine
okay and what you see about this this
trait or disease is that it's skipping
multiple generations and then it
manifests itself down here I'm not
getting any arrow so I'm just gonna use
this pointer here so here you see there
are several individuals there's a male
and a female with the disease and its
results from a relationship between two
first cousins
so only in this case does the disease
sort of appear and you can think of this
as a recessive trait in this case it's
autosomal recessive so for PKU this is
exhibiting what's a type of inheritance
known as autosomal recessive
and the reason that it's recessive is
because if an individual just has one
copy of a functional enzyme then they
don't have the disease okay so you can
see there's only individuals that have
both defective versions which are
labeled lowercase a here that exhibit
the disease okay so in the case of PKU
lowercase a represents the defective
enzyme and uppercase a denotes a
functional enzyme now it's not shown
here but it's possible that our
ancestors sort of like above this
parental generation also exhibited this
disease such that there would be a sign
that this is being inherited across
generations so that's not as obvious in
this disorder because it's a very rare
genetic disorder but more common
disorders such as colorblindness show a
more clear clear inheritance from
generation to generation
so um is anyone anyone here colorpoint
I asked just to know how to set up my
slides as well no one's colorblind okay
we have a that's good then you'll all
see the difference between the image on
the left on the image on the right so if
you have normal vision that's what you
see on the left from this fruit stand
but for those that are missing the red
photo pigment in your cone cells you're
you exhibit colorblindness and you had
this fruit stand would look like the
image on the right okay so this is a
clear example of an inherited trait in
humans and this is an example of
inheritance pattern that would be
similar to human color blindness and
here you can see a clear example where
you have an affected individual and
affected Mal here that now has
five daughters none of which exhibit the
phenotype or disease but several of
those daughters give rise to progeny
sons that have the disease okay so in
this case you see this trait skips a
generation but essentially the
grandfather here has passed on the trait
to his grandsons okay and so color
blindness is a little bit different from
PKU
not only in the fact that it's more
frequent so it's about 10% of mouths
exhibit color blindness in the
population but also you see with PKU you
had both a female and a male affected
and in this case you're seeing a
preponderance of affected males which
seems to be not random okay
and so this colorblindness exhibits a
different type of inheritance pattern
which is known as sex linked recessive
and I'm going to come back to this
inheritance pattern at the end of the
lecture because it's actually this type
of inheritance pattern which helped
researchers about a hundred years ago
make the connection between the unit of
heredity the gene and chromosomes
okay so we'll talk about a another
example of this type of inheritance
pattern at the end okay so for today
what we're going to talk about is we're
gonna start with some of the basic laws
of autosomal inheritance and so we're
gonna talk about Greg Ulm regor Mendel
and his seminal studies in the pea plant
and then towards the end of the lecture
we're going to talk about sex linkage
and I'm going to tell you about work
done in fruit flies and specifically
their eye color trait which led to the
linkage between the behavior of genes
and the behavior of chromosomes okay so
that's what we have in store for today
okay so first I'm gonna tell you a
little bit about what enabled Mendel's
theory I guess I could start over here
so what enabled Mendel's theory and I
presume that most of you have heard
about Mendel before so there might be a
little bit of a reminder for you but I
also hope that we kind of make a very
clear connection connection between
Mendel's theory and the behavior of
chromosomes so Mendel did his seminal
studies using the pea plant and one
aspect of pea plant biology that was
really essential for Mendel's theory is
that you can both self pollinate pea
plants meaning you can take the male
gametes from a pea plant and made it to
the female gametes from the same pea
plant so it's entirely within the same
plant okay so you can self pollinate
meaning you do a cross you basically
cross a plant to itself which obviously
we can't do with humans you can't do
with many organisms or you can cross
pollinate meaning you take the the male
gamete from one plant and you combine it
with the female gamete from a different
plant okay and as we go through Mendel's
experiments you'll see how this was used
to define the rules of inheritance
another property of the of the pea
plants and something that Mendel took
advantage of was he chose traits of pea
plants that exhibit exhibited a very
clear dominant or recessive phenotype
okay you sure I'm okay
so he used visible traits visible traits
with a very clear dominance or recessive
nasai and if we go back to our example
of PKU you can see how this human
disorder the genes that determine this
disorder the alleles have a very clear
dominance or recessive miss on the
dominant allele is often odd denoted
with a capital letter in this case for
PKU we used capital letter a or the in
this case the disease allele was lower
cased heir a and that's recessive and if
an allele has dominance what that
essentially means is that being
homozygous for the dominant allele is
equivalent to having just one copy of
that allele okay and so I think if you
think of the PKU example this is very
clear because the the disease phenotype
results from a defective enzyme right so
if you just have one copy of the enzyme
that's functional then the the human can
have wild-type or normal function okay
so in order to really lack function of
this enzyme you need to be homozygous
for the non-functional allele okay so
you need to not have any normal copy of
that enzyme because if you just have one
copy of that enzyme you're okay because
you have an enzyme that's functional and
will carry out that function in the
cells of your body
okay the last point I want to make is
that Mendel did his experiments starting
with what are known as pure breeding
lines okay so
started with pure breeding lines and
what I mean by pure breeding are these
are lines that if you take these plants
and just self cross them over and over
again generation to generation they will
only give rise to plants with traits
that reflect the parental generation
okay
so there's basically no variation and
you'll see in just a moment that another
way to denote pure breeding means that
for a certain trait you have an allele
combination which is homozygous okay so
another way to think of pure breeding
lines are these are plants that have a
homozygous allele composition homozygous
meaning that either they have two copies
of one allele or two copies of the other
allele okay okay I just want to make the
point that Mendel had to overcome a
number of hurdles in order to get these
results and Mendel is not exactly you're
sort of like you know clear clear
example of the success story okay so
Mendel applied to get a teaching
certificate in University and he failed
out okay and I'll quote one of
instructive his instructors who said I
quote he lacks in sight and the
requisite clarity of knowledge okay
so that guy feels stupid so next so
Mendel did his experiments and and the
significance of his work was never
recognized throughout his lifetime he
did his experiments in the 1850s and 60s
he died in 1884 he died not knowing at
all what the significance of his work
was because his work was then found
again in the early 1900s by the likes of
Thomas Hunt Morgan and others and they
made the connection between Mendel's
laws of inheritance and chromosomes and
it was really then that Mendel became
the father of genetics right because
then then there was a physical model for
how inheritance was working and but he
died before that happened right so he
didn't realize that he was the success
that we now know him to be another
interesting story
he started his work with mice he wanted
to like breed mice with different coat
colors but he got in trouble with with
his bishop because his bishop didn't
approve him of promoting sex among these
mice luckily his bishop doesn't didn't
take a plant biology course because of
course plants also have sex but he had
to under come a number of hurdles but he
took advantage of his garden and I was
talking to someone in my lab the other
day and she said you know what's great
about Mendel he had a garden and he just
didn't put it on Instagram so you know
he used his garden to his advantage and
so with his modest garden he came up
with what are now known as the rules of
inheritance and I'll start with Mendel's
first law so Mendel's first law is that
every adult has a pair of genes for a
given trait and these are now what we
refer to as alleles and we now refer to
them as genes as well Mendel did not use
the term gene he just had these abstract
sort of units of heredity okay so his
first law states that every adult has
two sort of units of heredity they can
be different and that they split during
the formation of the gametes okay and
the probability that
Gami will have a given allele or a given
unit is equal probability okay so what I
hope you can see is that this law which
is stated up there is a direct result of
the segregation of homologous
chromosomes during meiosis 1 ok Mendel
did not know that but now looking back
we can see how this manifests itself and
so during metaphase during meiosis 1 you
recall that the homologous chromosomes
here line up at the metaphase plate and
they line up opposite each other such
that some of the gametes will get the
capital Y allele shown here and the
other half of the gametes will get this
lower case Y allele okay so there's a
50% probability of a gammy either having
one or the other okay and of course in
meiosis one this is referred to as a
reduction older vision because the Hama
homologs are split and so the genetic
content of the gametes are divided into
half okay so Mendel's first law the
evidence for it were the results of a
what is known as a monohybrid cross okay
so Mendel did what is known as a
monohybrid cross where he took pea
plants that pure bred for two were pure
breeding for two different traits well
one was their pea color so his yellow
peas versus green peas and he made a
hybrid where he takes a yellow plant
that arises from yellow peas and crosses
it to a
and from green pea okay
and this is known as the parental
generation and so the result of this
cross is that all of the peas were
yellow so a hundred percent this this
cross results and eat a hundred percent
yellow peas this is known as the first
filial generation or the f1 okay and
that should indicate to you which of
these traits is dominant because if you
take yellow peas and you cross it to
green peas and you get yellow peas that
means that the trait for yellow peas is
dominant okay so for the rest of this I
will denote the gene allele that confers
yellow peas as capital y and the gene
allele that encodes for green peas is
lowercase Y and you see what I'm doing
here is I'm putting the phenotype and
describing the phenotype there which is
just what the trait is that manifests in
the organism but the genotype which is
the combination of alleles of in the
organism I'm showing beneath the
phenotype okay and if these gene alleles
are splitting during gamete formation
and then recombining during the
formation of a new plant then in this
case this hybrid plant is going to be
it's going to have one allele that's
capital y and one allele that's
lowercase Y and because these two
alleles are different this situation is
known as heterozygous so this is a
heterozygous plant you can think of sort
of pure breeding being analogous to
homozygous because if you
cross yellow pea plant to itself you
will only get back yellow peas so it
breeds true you can think of a hybrid as
being equivalent to heterozygous because
there are two gene alleles okay
so then what Mendel did is he didn't
stop there he self he self
crossed or self pollinated he's f1
plants and looked at the resulting seeds
and so in f2 generation what he found is
that he got back
both the parental phenotypes so 70% 75%
of the progeny were yellow had yellow
peas and 25% had green peas okay so
there's this three-to-one ratio here
okay now we can think of this if we
think about this in terms of Mendel's
first law where there's a segregation of
these alleles during the formation of
gametes and there's an equal probability
of having either one of these alleles if
we think about this cross here these
plants both the male and female side are
producing gametes that are either big Y
or little Y so this would be the female
here and so because they're separating
and there's there's a 1/2 probability of
having either the capital y or little Y
allele for the male and there's also a
1/2 probability of having either of
these alleles for the female okay so if
you look at the possible combination of
gametes that could give rise to the f2
generation you have some that will be
pure breed
yellow okay and the probability here
would be the joint probability of having
this gammy and this gammy which is 1/4
you then have two classes here that have
one copy of the dominant allele and one
copy of the recessive allele all right
so these will have the same genotype and
these three will have the same phenotype
they'll all be yellow peas right and so
if you add up the probabilities of all
three of these you can see that 3/4 will
be yellow so 3/4 of the progeny will
have the yellow phenotype
and you can see that another quarter of
the progeny have the chance of getting
two copies of the recessive allele and
therefore will be green ok so just by
considering this as a probability
problem which is what Mendel did you can
explain the ratios of the progeny that
Mendel observed in his crosses okay and
I want to point out the parallels
between this simple cross with peak with
our peas and the inheritance pattern
shown by PKU or phenylketonuria
so notice here you have green peas in
the parental generation but Greenpeace
skips a generation and only appears
again in a subsequent generation okay so
that's a lot like PKU right where you
can see there's multiple generations
that go by where the trait doesn't
manifest itself but then it pops up
again in that later generation where you
have inbreeding in this family okay so
there there's a clear connection between
the results that Mendel got in cases of
human disease okay now we're gonna go on
and talk about Mendel's second law
[Music]
so Mendel's second law which is often
referred to as the law of independent
assortment and another fortuitous thing
in thinking about Mendel's experimental
design and set up which was fortuitous
he didn't know it at the time he chose
traits that actually were present on
different chromosomes of the pea plant
okay so the traits didn't exhibit what
is now known as linkage where they're
physically connected on the chromosome
okay so this law of independent
assortment can also be explained by
thinking about how chromosomes behave
during meiosis where the alignment of
homologous chromosomes chromosomes at
the metaphase plate of meiosis one is
essentially random okay so if we take a
look at this example here
you can see I've drawn one particular
configuration for the chromosomes and
I'm using sort of one gene pair here and
another gene allele pair here and so if
the chromosomes were aligned this way
then when they segregate during meiosis
one you'd get two classes of gametes
some that are capital y capital R and
another class that's lowercase Y and R
okay so that's one possibility but
what's equally probable
during the alignment of chromosomes
during meiosis one is that the
chromosomes line up like this so rather
than having the the dominant alleles all
on one side of the metaphase plate you
the dominant allele for one homologous
pair on one side and the other dominant
alleles on the other side okay so how
they arranged how these homologous
chromosomes arranged during meiosis is
totally random
okay and if they arranged like this
you'd get alternative types of gametes
you get gametes that are uppercase Y
lowercase R and lowercase Y uppercase R
okay so this law of an independent
assortment is can be completely
explained by the behavior of the
chromosomes during meiosis one okay so
now I'm going to take you through the
experiment that will illustrate this and
this type of experiment is what is known
as a dihybrid cross and so a dihybrid
cross is now a cross where you're taking
plants that differ in two traits rather
than just one
okay so dye stands for two and in this
case we're going to consider both pea
color again the pea colors are yellow
and green but now we're also going to
consider P shape so you can have peas
that are round and peas that are
wrinkled all right I'm gonna make use of
this board again
so let's consider the round wrinkled
case if you set up a cross between a
plant that was from a round seed and a
plant that was from a wrinkled seed and
let's say the round phenotype or the
round allele is dominant what would you
expect to see in the f1 so you have yes
Carlos you'd see all round exactly right
okay so let's go through now this cross
so we're gonna have a parental cross
where Mendel took two pure breeding
lines one of them is has yellow round
peas and he crossed the plant from a
yellow round pea with a plant that was
derived from a green wrinkled pea okay
and we already know yellow is dominant
and as Carla Carlos just pointed out if
round is dominant then you'd expect all
the peas to be round as well so in the
f1 generation what you get what Mendel
found is you have a hundred percent of
the progeny that are yellow round piece
okay and then similar to the monohybrid
cross Mendel self crossed this these f1
plants and by self crossing them he
observed a number of different
he observed a number of different
classes of progeny so he got back the
parental types yellow round he also got
back this other parental type green
wrinkled okay so these because these
were the same combination of traits that
were present in at least one of the
original parents are known as parentals
their parental they have the same
parental phenotype as one of the
original parents but what Mendel
observed was two other classes of
progeny which were different
combinations of these traits that
weren't present in the original parental
generation so those were yellow wrinkled
peas and green round piece so you'll
notice that this combination of traits
yellow and wrinkled is not one of not
present in the parental generation this
is all f2 this is f2 continued you also
see green and round we're not present in
the parental generation so these are
referred to as being non parental so
these this non parental class is a
unique combination of traits that wasn't
present in the original parents ok and
what Mendel noted was that in these
dihybrid crosses he always got a
stereotypic ratio of 9 to 3 to 3 to 1
for these different
classes of combinations of traits okay
now we have to think about the
probability what what leads to this
characteristic ratio and again we can
think about this just in terms of
probabilities and these different gene
pairs segregating independently of each
other so we already talked about for a
monohybrid cross for p color 3/4 of the
progeny is yellow right because they at
least have one dominant allele for color
and 1/4 are green okay so the
probability of having this phenotype is
3/4 the probability of being green is
1/4 and you can consider peed shape as
just a sin just a separate monohybrid
cross where the round the dominant
phenotype is also going to be present at
3/4 probability so three quarters are
going to be round and 1/4 is going to be
wrinkled okay so now if we just consider
these different classes of progeny here
we can consider two monohybrid crosses
and what's the joint probability of
being both yellow and round ok so the
joint probability of being yellow and
round is 3/4 times 3/4 so if we have 3/4
times 3/4 that's going to equal 9/16
okay now if we consider yellow and
wrinkled that's the joint probability of
3/4 and 1/4 so this probability is being
3/4 times 1/4 which is equal to 3/16
green and round is similar it's 1/4
probability of being green and a 3/4
probability of being round so again you
have 1/4 times 3/4 which equals to 3/16
and the least probable class is being
homozygous recessive for both allele
alleles because there's a
1/4 probability of being recessive for
each so the joint probability of having
all recessive alleles as 1/4 times 1/4
or 1/16 okay so you could draw a massive
punnett square and also derive this but
really you can just consider it as two
separate monohybrid crosses and then
just calculate joint probabilities okay
any questions on Mendel before I move on
I'll just point out one thing about
Mendel's second law this is this is a
rule that I'm gonna break now in just a
minute
and this law of independent assortment
assumes that there is no linkage in an
other war in other words it seeing this
type of inheritance pattern really
depends on the two genes not being
physically connected to each other on
the chromosome okay now we're going to
talk about fruit flies and specifically
we're going to talk about a certain
trait in fruit flies which is their eye
color
I brought some pets to class today and
so we're going to talk about the white
mutant phenotype where the fruit flies
have a white eye color so I have three
pairs of vials here and one of them
there's the white mutant and you're
gonna see that has white eyes and then
there's also a corresponding sort of
normal red-eyed flies and the other vial
so I'll just pass these around hopefully
there's enough light that you can see
the eye color
you're able to see the eye color Jeremy
is yeah you might have to come up to the
board lights at the end of class if you
want to see it really well okay so we're
gonna fast forward from Mendel now and
talk about researchers who picked up on
Mendel's work in the early 1900s and
specifically I'm going to tell you about
research done in the lab of Thomas Hunt
Morgan who had a fly lab at Columbia so
we're going to talk about Thomas Hunt
Morgan and actually we're gonna focus a
lot on work done in Morgan's lab in the
next couple lectures because it turns
out his lab also made the first genetic
map and we'll talk about that in
Friday's lecture so what the type of
inheritance that Morgan defined is what
is now known as sex-linked inheritance
where a given trait isn't a sorting
independently of an organism sex but is
somehow connected to it okay and I want
to sort of return your attention to this
example of human color blindness where
there appears to be some sort of
connection between the disease phenotype
in this case colorblindness
and the gender of the individuals right
so you see this disease is only
affecting males okay and this type of
inheritance pattern while observed in
humans was really explained by work done
in flies on this white mutant that
you're carrying and through the class
okay so sex-linked inheritance the
explanation for that is this is a trait
that's carried by a special type of a
chromosome known as a sex chromosome
okay so fortunately for us flies like
humans have a similar set or we have
male flies and humans have an X in a Y
chromosome okay so it's the inheritance
kind of is similar between flies and
humans when considering sex linkage and
females have two x's okay so the
presence of these sex chromosomes was
known in the fly and it was known that
if a fly had an X in a Y chromosome it
would be a male fly and if a fly had two
x chromosomes it would be a female fly
and normally normal flies have red eyes
but Morgan's lab was interested in
variation in organisms and they searched
and searched for flies that had abnormal
characteristics or traits and what they
found in Morgan's lab was a mutant fly
it was a spontaneous mutant but this fly
had white eyes and it was male so they
find found a single white-eyed male
which they continued to study for some
time so they sort of defined some of the
rules of its inheritance
so what Morgan and his lab did was they
set up a set of crosses that that look a
lot like Mendel's crosses okay so you
have a white-eyed male they took a
white-eyed male and they crossed this
white-eyed male to a red-eyed female
okay and if you cross a white-eyed male
to a red-eyed female what Mendel the
result was actually similar to what
Mendel had predicted which is that a
hundred percent of the Flies had red
eyes okay so that's similar what to what
you would expect from a monohybrid cross
where red eyes is dominant so I'm going
to refer to the red-eyed allele as an X
with a capital R and the white eyed
allele is an X with a lowercase R okay
because this gene is present on the X
chromosome but it's not present on the Y
chromosome okay so the Y chromosome is
really small and so the X chromosome has
all of its genes are basically present
in one copy in the mouth okay and that's
gonna manifest itself in that sex
linkage okay so then they took this f1
generation where you have red eyed males
and they crossed siblings so they did a
sibling cross the one failing of flies
as a genetic system is you can't they
can't self cross you have to have a male
and a female so they crossed two
individuals in this f1 generation and
what they found again similar to what
Mendel would predict is that 75% of the
Flies had red eyes and 25% had white
eyes so this is behaving a lot like like
the yellow trait in peas right
except that all of the white eyed flies
in this f2 generation all of these white
I had felt when I'd flies were male so
only the males were getting this trait
of white eyes okay and you can see that
that's very much reminiscent of
colorblindness where you have a
grandfather that has white eyes right
and the grandfather is essentially
passing on this trait to his grandsons
okay so this pattern of inheritance that
happens in the fly is very similar to
that that happens in humans okay so now
let's think about how this if we can
explain this by thinking about
chromosomes segregating so if we think
about the this f1 generation we have
red-eyed males or actually let's do the
parental cross first where we have white
eyed males and we have red-eyed females
so all of the females are going to get
their X from their dad and they're going
to get a wild type copy of this gene
from their mom so all the females are
heterozygous for the white gene so I'm
gonna call it the white gene because
that's what it's called and flies if you
when they name the genes based on the
mutant phenotype so if you mutate it and
it results in white eyed flies then they
call it the white gene all the males are
gonna have a functional copy of the
white gene and thus all of these f1
flies are red-eyed okay so now these
siblings are mated all the females are
heterozygous for this gene the males all
have a functional copy of the gene so
they're going to make gametes that are
either a functional X that's functional
for this I color
or the y-chromosome okay
so now what you see is that all of the
females are going to get this normal
copy of the gene from dad and thus are
gonna have red eyes whereas half the
nails are gonna get a functional copy
from mom and therefore have red eyes but
the other half of the males are going to
get this non-functional variant that
can't produce red pigment and therefore
are going to be white okay so this here
is your white class and you can see
because males only have one X chromosome
the only class of progeny that's going
to be white eyed here are those males
that occur with a quarter of frequency
okay one thing I want you to think about
over the next couple days and I'll I'll
sort of take you through it at the
beginning of next lecture is what would
happen if you set up a reciprocal cross
here right what if you made it red I'd
males to white I'd female okay and I
want you to tell me what you expect
would result so my question for next
Friday is what if you took red eyed
males and mated it to white eyed females
so I want you to think about this and I
want you to think how this is different
from Mendel's experiment what if you did
a reciprocal reciprocal cross for let's
say the P color how would these two
different crosses compare with each
other okay and we'll talk about that at
the beginning of Friday's lecture and
we'll also talk about the first genetic
map which was actually created by an
undergraduate so stay tuned for that see
you on Friday
you